yeah I was very lucky in the sense that
my father struck this balance I'm a
mother as well where it was not about
the result and it was always about the
effort I remember like I had we lived we
had the privilege of living in London
three different times because my dad
worked for Pepsi International we were
moved all over the world right and I
remember we were I was there it was
third or fourth grade and I was in the
American School in London at one point
and he you know he came back my grades
came in and he was like okay we need to
talk about this I go and he goes I that
this the the B minus the C plus here I
don't care about that he goes it's this
section here on effort where you have a
c that's the one that bothers me and I
was like and it sank and I go what he
goes I don't care about the result I
want you to work hard whatever you do
and since that moment it's interesting
how that stayed with me I was like okay
I was at work I'll just work hard I work
hard and and it and it did stay with me
so I never had that they never imposed
on me you have to go to this school or
that school it was never about that but
it was understood that that we were
expected to work our butts off you know
not take these opportunities for granted